[Musique]
bonjour belal bonjour poli il ya un mot
qui revient ce matin dans les quotidiens
chantage absolument et vous venez d'en
parler d'ailleurs avec l'hymne dans la
dans la chronique économie le chantage
c'est évidemment le chantage de moscou
qui a
qui a interrompu ses livraisons de gaz
russe à la bulgarie et la pologne et ce
mot de chantage c'est celui qui est
utilisé par ours ou la fin des relais
yonne la présidente de la commission
européenne alors la correspondante du
monde à bruxelles rappelle que si ces
deux pays la pologne et la bulgarie sont
très dépendants au gaz russe ils ne
représentent à eux deux que 8% des
importations de l'union européenne la
question est donc quel pays au pluriel
seront les prochains sur la liste et
l'article de rappeler je cite si
l'allemagne se retrouvent privés de gaz
russe ce sera une toute autre affaire
est en effet pour la presse allemande
ces sanctions sont un signal à
destination de berlin tout à fait et
c'est exactement le titre de cette
analyse du du quotidien frankfurter
allgemeine l'éditorialiste du quotidien
conservateur un rappel que la décision
de moscou d'arrêter ses livraisons de
gaz à la pologne et la bulgarie ne
causera pas de difficultés importantes
pour ces deux pays puisque l'union
européenne pourra compenser cette
absence de livraison en revanche elle
doit être comprise comme un signal
d'avertissement est un test pour
l'allemagne le frankfurter allgemeine
fustige le gouvernement de l'afssaps
pour avoir en fait trop déclaré
publiquement que l'allemagne était
vulnérable au niveau de ses importations
de gaz russe ils critiquent plus
généralement la gauche allemande d'avoir
été naïve vis-à-vis de la puissance
militaire de moscou est la solution pour
notre éditorialiste c'est une allemagne
je cite - décourager plus confiante en
elle même et en ses partenaires ce
serait le bon signal envoyé à moscou et
entre temps le guardian souligne que la
russie continue de générer des les arts
d'euros grâce à ses exportations de gaz
et de pétrole absolument et alors
accrochez-vous parce que le chiffre est
assez
vertigineux il faut savoir que donc
selon le guardian la russie a doublé ses
revenus tirés des exportations de
pétrole et de gaz russe depuis le début
de l'invasion en ukraine ça représente
combien ça représente 62 milliards
d'euros dont 44 proviennent simplement
des importations de l'union européenne
alors comment on arrive à ce phénomène
le guardian explique je cite même si les
exportations de la russie ont été
réduites par la guerre et par les
sanctions la domination du pays donc la
russie en tant que source de gaz a
signifié que la coupure des
approvisionnements a fait monter les
prix et donc le garden si vous voulez
poursuit c'est simple la russie a pris
l'union européenne dans un piège puisque
à chaque fois qu'il y aura de nouvelles
restrictions et bien à chaque fois les
prix vont monter sur le plan
diplomatique cette fois les efforts du
secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio guterres est tout à fait alors
vous l'avez dit un peu plus tôt antonio
gutiérrez et est arrivé à kiev hier il
était à moscou sauf que le correspondant
du monde dans la capitale russe écrit
d'emblée que cette visite n'a fait que
démontrer le gouffre qui existe entre la
vision russe du conflit est celle des
pays ou des nations qui essayent
d'obtenir à minima un cessez le feu donc
le correspondant poursuit nous décrit
cette visite en russie en tonneau goûter
rsa rencontré sergueï lavrov le ministre
des affaires étrangères russe mais aussi
vladimir poutine qui lui a répété en
fait ce que la russie déclarent depuis
plusieurs semaines à savoir que les
accusations de massacres abuja sont faux
ce que tout ça alors sa phrase exacte
c'est vous avez été trompés à 10,1
vadimir poutine a en tonneau goûter
reste donc pour le monde le résultat de
cette visite en russie était connue
d'avancé
aucune signification qu'une négociation
pardon significative ne pourra avoir
lieu avant la bataille au donbass qui
est pour le dombass qui est perçu comme
essentiel du point de vue de moscou
j'ajoute qu'antonio goûter est attendu
aujourd'hui à bout de chela il est en ce
moment
à bord on a brodé en cas donc ce sont
des villes de la banlieue de kiev ont
été commises des excès des exactions qui
sont imputés aux forces russes alors on
va revenir sur le fait que la russie
elle semble tout de même peut-être
s'enliser dans l'ombre basse tout à fait
alors elles piétinent selon se tait ce
titre de libération ce qui signifie à
peu près la même chose le journal
rappelle que certes les autorités
ukrainiennes et ça c'est assez rare pour
être notée ont reconnu une avancée de
l'armée russe qui a pris quelques
quelques plusieurs petites villes mais
poursuit le quotidien les opérations
militaires russes dans la région
orientale ne semble pas plus réussie que
les précédentes ans et que la russie
s'est redéployée en fait à réviser ses
objectifs pour se concentrer sur le
dombass mais libération cite le
pentagone et le ministère de la défense
britannique qui affirment chacun que les
problèmes de l'armée russe ne sont
toujours pas réglés les mêmes qui existe
depuis le début de cette offensive en
ukraine à savoir deux points noirs
principaux le manque de coordination au
sein de l'armée mais aussi un moral des
troupes qui serait taux plus bas on va
passer à la politique en france nous
sommes toujours dans les conséquences de
l'élection présidentielle et on va pas
ressasser dans le figaro tout à fait
alors on le voit ici le figaro qui est
donc un quotidien de droite de la droite
entrepreneuriale et conservatrice titre
à propos du chef de la gauche radicale
qu'il tente une opa sur les partis de
gauche alors on sent qu au figaro il est
aujourd'hui se faire plaisir de comparer
jean luc mélenchon un grand baron du
capitalisme financier il n'empêche ces
jours ci le parti de jean luc mélenchon
qui a fait 22 % à la présidentielle
la france a soumise est en négociations
avec les autres partis de gauche qui ont
été ultra minoritaire dans cette
présidentielle un aucun d'entre eux n'a
atteint les 5 % pour créer une grande
alliance et se présenter en front uni
aux élections législatives du mois de
juin sauf que ces négociations ne se
passe pas apparemment si bien que prévu
le quotidien explique que la france en
soumises de jean luc mélenchon aurait
lâché une bombinette ce c'est le terme
dans ces négociations à savoir qu'ils
souhaitent intégrer dans le programme
commun de cette gauche une forme de
désobéissance
possible au niveau des traités européens
ça ça ne passe pas du tout avec le parti
socialiste mais aussi avec les verts
bref il y a des divergences de fond il y
a aussi des rancoeurs personnelles
puisque le quotidien explique que jean
luc mélenchon savoure ce moment qui est
une revanche pour lui par rapport à ses
anciens partis et le quotidien fini en
citant l'un des élus qui participent à
ces négociations pour avoir une petite
idée de l'état d'esprit eh bien il dit
l'état d'esprit général n'est pas bon
comme ça au moins ça c'est dit enfin on
va passer à cette histoire qui se passe
aux etats unis anna juillet l'un
absolument alors quand on vous dit
nashville tennessee cher pauline ça vous
fait pour ce à quoi la musique country
johnny cash c'est exact
on peut même ajouter elvis presley qui a
enregistré ses grands tubes là bas
nashville c'est la capitale de la
country music aux etats unis c'est une
ville qui est définitivement rock'n'roll
sauf que le monde nous raconte
aujourd'hui qu'il est parti en fait le
monde est parti en reportage chez un
pasteur évangélique de nashville qui a
décidé de lutter contre l' influence de
sa tente dans la société alors là je
vous dis ça et en même temps on voit le
titre l'article on voit pas le verlan
voilà on voit pas le rapport entre les
deux sauf que selon ce pasteur qui
s'appelle gré glock l'un des outils d'
influence de satan ou du grand mal un
peu importe ce qu'on veut l'appeler eh
bien ce sont les livres de la saga
twilight et harry potter sa façon de les
décrire je vous le site ans c'est lui
qui parle ces livres sont démoniaques
plein de sorts de métaphores et de
nécromancie ce qui est dans les cercles
mystique la magie pour relever les morts
et donc ce pasteur à la solution il a
décidé d'organiser des autodafés dans
son église c'est à dire de brûler des
livres de la saga d'harry potter et de
twilight il faut quand même savoir que
son église évangélique c'est plusieurs
milliers de personnes merci beaucoup
bilal c'était la revue de presse